hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to monster legends now the
developer this game approached me and
asked if I wanted to be paid to promote
their game and I said [ __ ] do you know I
play this game who's supposed to be my
dirty little secret no one's supposed to
know but I said yes because like many
other brand deals that I've done in the
past it affords me the opportunity to
donate to charity and this time around
we'll be donating $10,000 to the miracle
foundation if you don't know about the
miracle foundation please check out the
website we'll provide a link in the
description along with the proof of
donation by the time you guys are
watching this the donation has already
been made so thank you to social point
games from allowing that to happen and
thank you guys for watching now let's
get into the game now admittedly I am a
complete amateur at this
I started playing a few weeks ago and
then I kind of got addicted to it now is
playing it on and off but when they
approached me they gave me a whole bunch
of [ __ ] and it's awesome I don't even
know what half of this stuff does I mean
obviously I know the basics of the game
and I'll give you guys an overview of
what it's doing but they gave me a whole
bunch of new monsters and especially
this one monster that they definitely
want me to show to you guys called
Erebus who's aptly named the boss now
he's a new character that works off of
cards and [ __ ] and if you don't know
about the game in general here's the
basic summary that I can make you breed
and hatch monsters and use them to fight
and get gold and gems and then grow food
to feed your monsters make the monsters
bigger be able to go through dungeons
and crap and get more stuff so that you
can do more things and kill more
monsters that's the long and the short
of it but that is definitely the short
of it because the real game is much more
in-depth than that if you played city
builders in the past this one thankfully
a lot of these city builders games have
you waiting around for a long time and
not that this one doesn't because
obviously you're waiting for your crops
to grow you're waiting for your gold to
get in you're waiting for a lot of stuff
but in this game in particular there's
always something to do while you're
waiting which is awfully nice and
doesn't always happen with other things
so you got your farms over here that you
got
food for and I've already been growing
stuff so I'm just gonna repeat
everything that I did but I guess I'll
show it because that's probably
important you get you get your food here
jungle peanuts snow peas sea grapes red
tiger nut you know whatever you got
standard staples in nutrition at least
four monsters anyway so if you want to
grow sea grapes you go wait no you go
with the gold that you got and that's
gonna be growing up some food and then
you use the food to grow your monsters
and they boosted a lot of my monsters
and they actually gave me some new
monsters that I don't know and one of
them that I've been using just recently
who is by far my favorite just because
of how do fee he is is this guy right
here
his name is Ben but his monster name is
ROFL and he is the Internet shoved into
one box but only the stupid parts of the
internet you know the old 2011 internet
memes all shoved in there yet thanks Ben
thank you so much Ben
all the old memes that been shoved into
this one character because you can see
even on the screen it's an old rage
comics and I used to admittedly I used
to be the guy that goes to f7 you twelve
I went there all the time like every day
and it was hilarious
like for three solid weeks every day
that I went there I laughed my ass off
and this was years ago but I laughed my
ass off and then one day I went there
and all the funny was sucked out of it
all of the comedy had been squeezed out
of the comics and there was nothing left
for anyone so so what they want me to
show you is mostly battles and stuff and
they wanted me to show you
Erebus is his name is the name of the
boss and just because my OCD is getting
there's more islands that I don't have
yet but I'll get them later I probably
have enough given that they've given me
so much extra stuff they've probably
given me a bunch of stuff and by the way
this game is free it's another one of
those free-to-play games I mean there's
microtransactions obviously but I've
gotten this far well not this far
obviously because they've given me stuff
but I mean I got I was playing for a
long time without needing to buy
anything and they probably wouldn't want
me to encourage you not to buy anything
but my main point is that the game is
free and that's one of the reasons why
I'm happy to promote it because there's
really no risk in it just don't go too
deep with your parents credit card or do
what do I care so anyway you go into
mostly what I do because I'm a big
bubble blowing baby I don't really do
multiplayer a whole lot so I'm gonna try
it oh God
Search enemy oh god he's low level thank
goodness I'm gonna kick the crap out of
this guy oh man I'm so happy that he's
not gonna put up much of a fight
so anyway Erebus right here can just
smack the piss out of these guys I've
got a bunch of damage runes on him and
in you're out whoops that's not good
in your in your monster battle so you
can give them runes that give him like
more damage more speed more health just
basically buff them in a whole bunch of
ways but you're not been what are you I
gotta change my team because this isn't
right yeah what did you bud get out of
here give me bad minute Aras God give me
bye guys
geez okay I got my real team the dream
team is going on here love it alright
let's go well that seems a little bit
tougher I'm gonna find someone else
someone probably easier now you look
tough hmm
hmm yeah all right I'll try you guys see
there's so many monsters in this game
that I haven't actually seen a lot of
people but Ben is great because Ben has
a lot of abilities and he's I got him
buffed up on speed rooms so he's very
fast so straight flush let's just wipe
that guy out oh no he's gone and they
won't be able to get away from my minute
Taurus which is good because he's got
just tons and tons and tons and tons of
health thank you
all right so he's debuff down a bit was
gonna be good for me
accuracy increased you took down like
10% of my health so Ben also has various
different abilities that are rather
silly like trollolol which means that
they can't get they can attack for two
turns you get very speed which buffs
which d buffs them so that they're slow
and then falcon punch which is very nice
and not exactly a falcon punch but if it
misses it doesn't do jack crap so screw
that I'm on a double or nothing you it
better hit this time there we go thank
you very much and gone and that loses
their turn you can see the turn order at
the top of the game I do not claim to be
an expert at this game by the way like I
said I started off as an amateur I
didn't know what I was doing but once
you're as you're fighting along you get
a special move
this one's called labyrinthian
demolition I just want to do it because
it's there and I can show you guys and
it's really cool got it cool right he's
almost dead but he's debuff to hell and
back so he's not gonna be able to do
anything very speed alright just troll
alone sad I don't mind the carrot I
still love that monster that monster is
fantastic um let's see
gamblers ruin deals load our cabbage to
all so gambler ruin attacks all enemies
and you kind of want to do that first
but this one will do is take him out
boink
thank you
and I win and it's just as easy as that
but while you're off like if you play
these various games people can attack
you when you're doing your thing and
then you food perfect okay so the other
thing they wanted to show you because
they didn't give me enough stuff I've
got so much stuff I've got a little
Erebus egg and he's freaking adorable
even though he grows up to be all weird
and goopy but I've got an Erebus egg so
I'm gonna hatch that would you like to I
don't I don't want that sell it get out
of here yes sell it I don't even want it
I need to hatch my egg and maybe this is
why they gave me gems and gems are the
things that you get from either watching
ads or or buying them in bulk but I'm
gonna finish this right away because I
want to show you guys how about ski it's
adorable he's a little baby look at him
and so you got this guy and I don't know
if I have any places I'll put him with
its daddy and baby Erebus oh look at him
he's horrifying oh he's so ugly Vanna
Pagan Vanna pagan I'm gonna rename that
that's terrible
get out of here van up again I'm calling
bubble butt because I don't name enough
things bubble butt and I like bubble
butt okay so he's gonna be and this is
how you grow up a monster shove food
into his face as fast as you can oh geez
the teenage years he's still a little
awkward that is quite as cool as Papa
but then you get skills and you need to
assign them to your slots you probably
have seen something like this before
cold deck deals moderate dark damage 50%
chance and make it the target bleed okay
that sounds good I'll take that not that
I have any other options odds against
deals low special damage to all enemies
may apply damage reduction to targets
requires cooldown so basically there are
so many monsters in this game and each
of them has a very specific skill set
you get this enormous variety of
potential when you're going up against
enemy players or building your team and
you got to organize them in special
abilities that overlap with each other
and trying to find the best combination
there's there's a lot of strategy to be
done
in this so I don't know if I want that
low roller low roller that sounds like
crap I don't need that I need to raise
my level yep yep yep yep and shadow ski
risk premium deals heavy tark damage may
possess target requires cool down hot
damn sounds awesome
all right I'm gonna replace it steel
life cuz that's just one basic thing but
I need this other one risk premium and
now Erebus is the max level that he
could be or not the max level but at
least he's all grown up oh look at him
look at my little error but wow I should
have called them error but that's a much
better name I'm gonna call them I'm
gonna call them error but he's no bubble
but bubble BOTS too cute calm era but I
like to name all of my characters but
types there's dark type light type but
type boob type lots of times
alright so fast breeding oh that sounds
weird yeah why not let's do that alright
skill activated because the next thing
that they want me to show you is how you
make more monsters when a daddy monster
and a mommy monster love each other very
much
you take the boss and Bend for some
strange reason and you start breeding oh
go for it
oh geez why did you throw that cat Ben
okay so the breeding is done I did it
again just because I can and when it's
done breeding you get an egg and the egg
goes to the hatchery and then you can
even speed it up which I'm gonna do
because I have extra stuff a little
monster and I don't know what the
algorithm for getting a new monster it
might be totally completely random
because these monsters don't have
anything to do with this lightning bird
but I've got him so hey look at Schanke
he's so cute but anyway I'm not gonna
place him yet because I this this is
disorganized chaos in here right now
thank you fertility goddess for blessing
this land with better monster breeding
it is much appreciated okay the other
thing that I wanted to show you that I
actually enjoy is dungeon I'm actually
part way through this dungeon so the
dungeon basically explains itself you
traverse through a dungeon
you get rewards as you go through the
dungeon and you can fight so long every
time you log in the game but this one is
easy because my team is ridiculously
overpowered also the sounds of the game
are delightful I don't have headphones
in at the moment but it is just adorable
I need to give my minute or a AoE attack
Oh looks like they're not gonna even
need it there wait we got thug life we
got thug life thug life baby yep this is
where you throw the cat which is rather
bizarre attack but it works I guess and
yeah that's been that's been I love so
anyway that's pretty much monster
legends if you enjoy this game and wanna
try it for yourself please feel free to
click the link in the description below
it'll take you right to the page it is
totally free you can play it on any
mobile device and I think even on
Facebook I'm pretty sure but I don't
play it there I play it on my phone but
it is a lot of fun I actually be
recommend it and thank you to social
point games for helping me donate to the
miracle foundation and thank you
everybody out there for watching maybe
you'll find me in the game and probably
destroy me but now that I got a lot of
buffs from the developers maybe not so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
poor dear 40 digit